we've all felt the pinch of higher
prices and every month we get the data
how high is inflation now and just when
is it going to come down
well many of these price hikes are
driven by global factors the rising cost
of energy supply chain issues
some economists are increasingly talking
about something else being behind it
greed
the cost of living crisis is not
impacting everyone equally those at the
bottom are struggling to make ends meet
big businesses are posting bumper
profits
[Music]
so what's going on our company's
profiteering and Hiking up prices just
because everyone else is Sky News has
crunched the data on Greed inflation to
find out I'm Sally Lockwood with our
economics and data editor Ed Conway and
this is the Sky News Daily
discourse on inflation in Parliament in
governments and in the Bank of England
has been dominated by the need to curb
workers wages this is labor MP Richard
burgeon speaking in a House of Commons
debate about greed flation this approach
has ignored the elephants in the room
the role that corporations are now
playing in driving up inflation through
price hikes designed to boost their
profits and there is mounting evidence
that such corporate profiteering is
playing a very significant role in the
latest wave of inflation
Ed good to see you so we've had the
latest inflation figures which show that
we're finally out of double digit
inflation but that doesn't tell the full
story does it explain to us what you
made of these figures no that's the
weird thing actually kind of when you
when you look beneath that headline
number which which definitely is looks
like good news and there's kind of good
news
um actually the rest of the data the
rest of the detail was kind of a bit of
a shocker inflation is not like a level
it's just the rate at which price has
changed over the past year and the main
thing that was kind of pushing down that
rate was kind of just that the biggest
increases in Energy prices happened more
than a year ago so that it's it's just
where you are on that kind of spectrum
inflation just happens to have been not
quite as much of a shift a kind of shift
in gear over the past year it does it
still doesn't change the fact that price
is still going up and that people are
paying more and the energy bills are
still incredibly high and even though
they're going to come down more this
summer they're still much higher than
they were only a kind of a couple of
years ago so all of that stuff in terms
of our day-to-day lived experience is
still really it it will still feel like
a cost of living crisis it will still
feel like you know pretty pretty tough
both there and in the shops as well
because food food inflation is is crazy
high you know that's that's that's
nearly still it's nearly 20 it's come
down a tiny bit maybe that's plateaued
but you know you look at Food probably
we've all seen it haven't we you know
just your your daily shop your weekly
shop you're like God is that how much
you know tomatoes lettuce potatoes and
it's unsustainable isn't it I mean
people will not be able to afford I mean
people already can't afford to to make
ends meetings yeah on the face of it it
looked like good news and it's it's good
that that kind of the degree of pressure
and the acceleration was going down
but actually beneath the surface people
were looking at that in markets and came
Plumbing hell this really changes this
changes the story for us and as a result
they went out there and they're making
different bets and now they think the
bank of England is definitely going to
raise interest rates at that next
meeting but more importantly that
they're going to put them up to five and
a half percent okay so four and a half
at the moment up to five and a half
percent and doubly importantly you know
we all know this especially if you have
a mortgage the rate that you end up
paying on a fixed rate mortgage is not
the same as the bank of England rate but
it is influenced by it okay they go out
in the market and they they're making
their own kind of um Investments and
hedges and decisions that means you end
up paying maybe a little bit more maybe
a little bit less usually a bit more
frankly uh than that than that bangling
debate uh bank rate that now will change
the cost of mortgages if you are going
to refix your mortgage in the coming
months I'm afraid it looks like it's
going to be more expensive and it looks
like it's gonna be more expensive next
year as well so it's really interesting
you talk about you know what we can can
expect when it comes to interest rates
Ed because of course that's what the
government and the bank of England have
been have been using interest hiking
interest rates but also trying to
control wage growth in order to deal
with this issue of inflation but we're
increasingly hearing from economists
that there might be something else
behind it too this this issue of greed
inflation explain what that is it's I
mean it's it's either it's a kind of a
terrible term isn't it uh but people
like to kind of these made up portmante
words and things greed flesh and
stagflation you know all that stuff
greed inflation it's kind of a term that
that economists were talking about a
little while ago mostly actually in the
U.S and in Europe and they looked at the
the numbers on inflation they saw they
were high
they looked at profit margins you know
that companies were earning and they saw
those profit margins were getting bigger
as well and they thought to themselves
is this a sign that people that many
companies are taking advantage of this
period of higher prices
to raise their prices in order to
increase their profits in in order to
increase their profit margins and the
European Central Bank put out a really
interesting working paper looking at
this breaking down where inflation kind
of came from and you can do that it's
something called the GDP deflator and
you can slice it into a few different
parts and they found actually that was
the case in Europe for the last year or
so profits so uh profits as opposed to
wages were just about the biggest slice
explaining why inflation was going up so
that does look like you've got a
statistical explanation for greed
inflation as you call it
however I did the numbers so I did the
same exercise with the UK and so you can
take UK inflation break it down into
profits break it down as a labor break
it down into productivity and the
interesting thing on our end is that
actually you do see a bit of that the
kind of whatever the profits affect the
green inflation effect in the very
latest quarters but it's very different
to Europe you don't see as much of that
in the last year or so it does look like
this so far at least was a massive
energy price shock that has then come
across and is kind of affecting everyone
whether it's companies or whether it's
whether it's people but that being said
it's quite early days and this stuff is
kind of happening now you know like
businesses are still raising prices and
one of the interesting things about
those the latest inflation data we
talked about is that one of the things
that went up is is I think mobile phone
data charges and and phone call charges
and for a lot of those people a lot of
those companies that you know that
you're paying your your monthly bill to
you might have seen it they take RPI a
lot of the time sometimes CPI so retail
price index Consumer Price Index those
are those are rates of inflation and add
a couple of percent to them and because
CPI because inflation is so high that
means those mobile phone bills have gone
up a lot a lot and a big part of the
explanation for why inflation was a bit
higher than people thought was things
like that was mobile phone chargers
going up so is that maybe a sign of more
of this to come I don't know
back to our economics and data editor at
Conway
let's talk about food because that is
the thing that I think people are
becoming increasingly frustrated at
these soaring prices food inflation's
still at nearly 20 percent yeah
supermarkets also posting bumper profits
are they profiteering well I mean what
does the data tell you yeah I mean I
don't have a definitive answer really
except so because because part of the
difficulty is is working out the extent
to which
those profits were really really kind of
squeezed during the kind of covert
period which some people make an
argument for you can look at food prices
as well I'm gonna sorry I'm going to
give you a slightly Economist the answer
because I don't think there is a kind of
straightforward clear answer here you
know when you look at some of uh of the
prices in the UK so food prices
we are quite high in terms of the
inflation number right now so the rate
at which is going up each year and
remember that's that's what we're
talking about here inflation is always
about the rate how fast something is
accelerating it's not about the level of
prices
but when you look at the level of prices
in the UK and compare it across Europe
we're kind of amidst a low table when it
comes to our food prices in general
so right now food prices are going up
and it's miserable for everyone and I
know this doesn't help to hear it but
they are they have for many years been
quite a lot lower than in most of Europe
so what you're saying is we don't know
yet who if anyone is profiteering in the
supply chain we don't know who who that
may be and and could could margins from
supermarkets for instance could the
margins that they're making be adding to
the cost of living crisis for people
well that's that's that's exactly it I
mean that is it's that's the question
and because because we don't know the
extent to which these are kind of in a
vertical as reasonable profits
um the extent to which that money is
then just distributed through to their
workers or indeed as kind of is kept as
as as profits and indeed the extent to
which it's kind of reasonable and is
just based on on the way they do their
business
it's it's hard to know how much of it is
actual kind of yeah profiteering what we
do know is that
there are so many pressures on
on producers right now
there is such a high level of inflation
once upon a time we kind of had a pretty
good handle on what constituted normal
levels of inflation but I think because
everything's gone so Haywire because
Normal inflation is out the window and
you've got 20 food inflation and kind of
more than 10 inflation for a long period
which is now you know thankfully kind of
coming to an end
the compass is slightly offbeam at the
moment so understanding what is
reasonable and what's not is kind of
gone and I'm sure there are kind of
examples out there of companies taking
taking advantage I'm sure there are also
examples of companies who are doing very
well not necessarily because they're
taking advantage but because that's just
the nature of their business model I
mean look at some of the energy
companies if you're if you're a company
that has a load of wind turbines the
cost of generating electricity has not
gone up for you because you've still got
the same wind turbines maybe you're
spending a bit more for fuel on you know
uh sending boats out to deal with those
wind turbines or for steel for making
new wind turbines and stuff like that
but that's kind of marginal the scheme
of things you're not paying crazy kind
of levels of gas prices but because in
this country the marginal price for
electricity is set by what's going on
with the gas market you've had a period
now for a couple of years where if you
have wind turbines or indeed
hydroelectricity or any of these other
things you can make enormous amounts of
money not because of profiteering but
just because of the nature of the market
which is a little bit weird
dysfunctional and so it's that kind of
thing about that that's the problem with
the word profiteering is it kind of
implies you know people out there on the
streets trying to kind of do people over
it's a lot of these cases that's not I
mean I I don't discount that there could
be some of that going on because at
times like this who knows
um but I think a lot of the kind of
companies doing extraordinarily well at
the moment it's kind of just because
they're following the business model
they have done for some some time
they're not they're not driven by greed
any more than they normally are because
you know there's a Marcus and it's
profit-driven Market but it so happens
that whether through a regulatory system
like electricity or indeed through the
fact that you've got this terrible war
going on in Ukraine's prices have gone
all over the place
they've done quite well out of it and
and the perversity of it is that we are
all the rest of us are paying these
horrible prices in the supermarket or
for our mortgages or for our electricity
and all of these things and you see
someone else doing very well at the
moment and it's just it just adds to the
depression it feels unjust you've
mentioned various sectors uh that have
seen a large increase in profitability
energy supermarkets mobile phone
companies is a government doing anything
to investigate this or to regulate it a
lot of these like a lot of these
businesses are kind of regulated
businesses so take water like massively
in the headlines at the moment how much
can the government do that well it can
go to off what the regulator and say you
need to sort things out it can go to off
gem when it comes to electricity and
power and and gas bills and it can say
you need to kind of change the way
you're doing things but those are kind
of big seismic changes to the regulatory
system which they're always a bit
nervous about doing so they end up
trying to kind of you know nudge nudge
the the regulator and say you need to do
a little bit more I don't see much
nudging happening at my assignments I
don't see much nudging happening right
now that's the conservative load star
isn't it just not trying not to
intervene like like you say it's trying
not to intervene as much as possible and
letting the market resolve itself it's
often worked pretty well but I mean it's
just like the question is whether we're
in a different world now yeah you you
make a good point it is a conservative
value but interestingly we're not
hearing much noise from labor about this
either are we no no well not yet no but
a bit more than from the conservatives
but I think I think there is that an
issue that is kind of quite a
long-standing issue which is that in
this country over the last kind of
decade and a bit a lot of the the
profits within the economy as a whole
have gone towards Capital owners rather
than towards workers okay so when you
same thing if you're breaking down
inflation looking how much it's going to
to work as how much is going to profits
look across the entire economy how much
of the money we're generating is going
to you know shareholders Capital uh
versus workers
and that workers slice has got smaller
and smaller over the past few decades
which for a lot of people is another
sign of
I call it neoliberalism there are words
for it but it's not a sign for people
workers basically not getting what they
think is their fair share and people who
own businesses and own big Investments
doing very well out of it thank you very
much and I think that's the issue is is
this is this kind of an extension of
what we've seen in the recent years or
is it is it something else and I feel
like I always do this to you every time
we have a chat head
um is there any light at the end of the
tunnel for consumers in all of this
Bleak news I think that like you know
the fact that inflation is no longer
double digits is is genuinely good news
you know touch wood but we're past the
worst in terms of the rate of increase
the issue though salary
it's the levels that matter it's the
levels of food prices the the kind of
upsetting thing about inflation is it
goes up very easily but often when it
goes up crazy amounts it's not like it
kind of cut afterwards it comes down to
the to where it was before and so the
question is how much of that increase is
permanent how much of the time are you
looking going to be looking at a menu
and you know in McDonald's and going oh
well that's just that from now on that's
the price of a Big Mac that that's the
thing things things get sticky and they
stay there and and it's a weird thing no
one knows how to predict this stuff
that's why I'm always nervous about
about these questions which are totally
reasonable questions no one knows how to
predict the bank of England doesn't have
look at look at what how you know good
stroke terrible a job the bank of
England has done trying to predict
inflation it's been disastrous so no one
knows and that's partly because it's a
psychological phenomenon how much do
these things take hold in people's
brains and they think inflation's here
to stay so I'm going to ask for higher
wages and therefore your trap situation
where it keeps on going higher and
higher and in light of that I guess
we'll chat again sooner thanks so much
thank you
my thanks to Ed Conway and to you for
listening to the Sky News Daily with me
Sally Lockwood this episode was produced
by Soylent aparicio and Amy Lakin the
editor was Paul stanworth